now let's look at the code for getting
an entity out of the datastore since you
know the key for a profile entity as
Marcus explained you can use the key to
easily yank that the entity out of the
datastore you've already learned how to
save entities and how to view them in
the admin console the obvious next step
is to extend the conference center
application to get the profile entities
back out of the data store with
objectify you use the offload function
to load an entity you can get an entity
by key or you can query for entities
that match search criteria you'll be
learning how to prevent ities by key
first then in the next lesson you'll
learn how to query for entities that
satisfy certain criteria let's take a
look at the code to get an entity out of
the datastore ah fee gets the objectify
service load loads the entity key is the
key of the entity to load and now means
do it now don't wait in other words do
it synchronously that's all well and
good but how do you get the key you need
to know the unique ID that was used to
generate the key remember how you use
the assigned D annotation to identify
user ID as the ID when creating a
profile entity the ID is used to
generate the key the ID isn't the key by
itself but it's essential to generating
the key so for any user who's logged in
your app can retrieve the user ID which
means you can generate the key and
consequently get the profile entity
directly from the datastore as we've
already learned the user is passed in
the call to the endpoints method and you
can simply get the user ID like this get
user ID to get a key you call the create
method on the key class and you need to
specify the kind of entity that you want
to retrieve here and she's actually a
variable so let's say we were creating a
key for recipe this would be recipe
class then you need to pass the ID that
was used to generate the key in this
case we're using user ID so now we know
the ID and we know the key we can get
the entity from the datastore using the
key now it's your turn to work on your
conference central app you need to
complete the get profile method by
in the to do to load and return the
profile entity you'll need to get the
user ID you'll need to create the key
and you get the profile and then you
return the profile when you've
implemented get profile you can try it
out in the api's explorer